this video was made possible by you
every sale of our limited edition
calendar supports what we do here at
Quant and our brand new 1224 calendar is
our most spectacular yet don't miss out
on your chance to own a special piece of
kots kazak
History the universe is going to die one
day but how well it turns out our Cosmic
fate will be decided by a fight between
two
TI the two Warriors deciding the fate of
the universe our universe was born 14
billion years ago in the Big Bang and
has been expanding ever since for some
reason new empty space is being created
out of nothing between galaxies space
itself is becoming bigger will it go on
forever or will it stop one day today we
think the universe is at the mercy of
two Cosmic demigods fighting for
dominance the first one is all the stuff
in the universe galaxies gas Dark Matter
while they're very different they just
want to do one thing get together matter
is attracted by matter pulled together
by gravity and gravity also pulls on the
universe as a whole slowing the
expansion that started at the big bang
our second Warrior is empty space while
it seems well empty and Powerless empty
space has an intrinsic energy we don't
really have an idea what this energy is
or why it's there it's really a
placeholder that fills a blank in our
understanding of reality but it's got a
cool name Dark Energy Dark Energy pushes
things apart a sort of anti-gravity that
accelerates the cosmic expansion so we
have all the matter in the universe
pulling in and empty space infused with
dark energy pushing out whoever wins
will kill the universe in fun ways but
who will win if it all depends on the
mysterious Dark Energy will its strength
stay the same a common assumption just
because it keeps our model simple or
will it get weaker or will it get more
powerful over
time one constant dark energy heat death
if the strength of dark energy stays
constant it will win the war since space
is growing matter is getting more and
more diluted like sugar in a cup being
filled with more and more tea but as the
UN expands new empty space is created
which brings more dark energy which
pushes everything apart even more which
creates more empty space which makes the
universe grow even faster a feedback
loop that will make the universe expand
at an exponential rate every 12 billion
years or so it will double in diameter
forever but while dark energy is winning
the war matter is winning at least one
battle at Short distances it can keep
things together local Galaxy bubbles can
overcome the push of dark energy in a
few billion years our local group of
galaxies will merge into a gigantic ball
with trillions of stars it will soon
become our last view of the cosmos all
other galaxies will be pushed away by
the expansion for us it will look like
the rest of the universe is rushing away
until in a few hundred billion years we
won't see other galaxies at all we'll be
alone surrounded by a seemingly infinite
Dark Void and about 100 trillion years
all the stars of our Super Galaxy will
have died out all gas that could create
new stars has been consumed and no new
gas can come in the Galaxy will be dark
and filled with Stellar corpses over
quadrillions of years white dwarfs and
neutron stars will slowly cool until
becoming truly dark turning off the last
Lights of the universe all structures
big and small will slowly dissolve one
by one all dead stars planets will leave
the Super Galaxy which slowly dissolves
over six billions of years every object
will end up on its own which means that
dark energy takes over again creating
more and more empty space between
everything objects will be so far apart
that it will be as if each had a
universe for itself not much happens
anymore until in a good old years all
black holes will have evaporated in the
end entropy and dark energy won't stop
until their job is finished over time
spans you might as well call Forever all
remaining structures might even dissolve
into single particles that will be
pushed away from each other by an Ever
growing empty space imagine a whole
universe with just a single lonely
particle traveling through
nothingness this is the final State the
true end the big freeze or heat death a
completely featuress cold and eternally
expanding Universe nothing will ever be
able to happen again
forever well that was a bummer what else
could
happen two increasing Dark Energy big
rip what if Dark Energy gets stronger in
this case empty space won't just win
over matter it will literally rip it to
pieces in the big freeze scenario
mattera lost the war but won some
battles but here matter wins nothing
dark energy is growing stronger over
time over overcoming the pull of gravity
and creating new empty space at smaller
and smaller distances in this scenario
things will escalate quickly it could
start as early as 20 billion years from
now first Dark Energy will create empty
space between individual galaxies our
galaxy will leave its local cluster and
begin to drift alone in a rapidly
inflating and ever darker Cosmos some
billion years later empty space starts
to push between individual Stars
dissolving the Galaxy if you live on a
planet in a star system the night's Sky
will start looking sad and gloomy as
other stars are pushed too far away to
be seen a few million years after the
sky turns dark Dark Energy starts to
create empty space inside star systems
your planet is pushed away from its star
and all life in the universe freezes to
death there's not much time left as a
few months later dark energy is creating
empty space inside solid objects Stars
neutron stars planets asteroids
everything solid is being ripped into
pieces if you're on a spaceship you only
have a short time before you are ripped
apart half an hour later even atoms
destroyed as new space is being created
so furiously that electrons and nuclei
are separate it now the universe has
just a fraction of a second left in this
final moment only dying black holes
remain drained and defeated by dark
energy they're tiny septi of times
smaller than an atom and they explode
with the power of a trillion supern noi
in a trillionth of an octillion of a
second finally the very fabric of
reality is torn to its core obliterating
SpaceTime itself the big rib space and
time have lost their meanings making it
impossible to predict what will happen
next three decreasing Dark Energy big
crunch poor matter but there is one
scenario where it wins if the strength
of dark energy decreases with time and
if this reduction is strong enough the
pull of gravity will win and all the
things in existence will move towards
each other unfortunately making the
universe collapse into itself no one
knows when this might begin but it could
be as soon as a few hundred million
years what will it look like as the
universe begins to contract over
billions of years galaxies and Galaxy
clusters approach each other until they
eventually collide
they're mostly made of empty space so a
collision is like the gentle merger of
two clouds at any rate first galaxies
and later individual stars get closer
and closer as the Universe goes on
collapsing you might worry about stars
and planets eventually crashing against
each other this will happen but it's not
your worst problem if space itself
shrinks this also concentrates all the
radiation emitted in the past by all the
stars supern noi and quazars that ever
existed now empty space
is filled with radiation the dark
nothing between stars is heating up
making life unpleasant and then
impossible as planets just burn slowly
at first then rapidly space gets as hot
as it was after the big bang stars are
pretty hot but now the space around them
is hotter they're literally boiled from
the
outside as the universe collapses into
itself all galaxies and All Stars merge
into a single bow of hot plasma the big
big crunch is
complete from here on there are two
possibilities either the universe will
collapse completely into a singularity a
point of zero size and infinite density
without space and time the way it might
have been before the Big Bang or the
universe could bounce back restarting
the cosmic expansion creating a new baby
Universe somewhat poetic really
everything died but everything is reborn
but to be clear we have zero evidence
that this has happened before or will in
the future so what will happen most
scientists think that dark energy will
stay constant so the likely fate of the
universe is heat death Eternal cold and
utter boredom which seems sad but has a
huge upside in this scenario we get to
have the universe for the longest it
gives us trillions of years to expand
jump from star to star maybe even from
Galaxy to Galaxy we might even find a
way to keep Consciousness around forever
we don't know so we just have to wait
and see and make the most of the amazing
Universe we have right
now hey you why don't you stick around
for a bit longer we want to tell you
about something that changed ktz gazak
forever kazak started out as a small
scale passion project but creating
animated science videos that are free
for everyone doesn't pay the bills damn
you reality in order to make ends meet
we had to take on real jobs during the
day and create kotar videos at night it
was tough but our dream of inspiring
people all around the world kept us
going then in 2016 everything changed
kazak's founder Philip demma had an idea
he wanted to create something inspiring
that would extend beyond the digital
YouTube Cosmos something tangible
something that would represent kot
kazak's view of the world and our belief
in Humanity's potential for greatness
his idea the kts kazak human era
calendar it establishes a new year zero
to include all people and cultures
around the world this new year zero
roughly 12,000 years ago signifies a
time when humans first started working
together on a larger scale laying the
foundation for modern society and
eventually our future ahead of us the
first human era calendar was a huge
success it sold out within a few hours
and inspired thousands of BBS around the
globe every year since then we've
created a new edition of the human era
calendar each one more spectacular and
successful than the last
it has enabled us to grow our team
improve our video quality and research
standards and still release our videos
for free for everyone this year's
calendar is extra special join us as we
conduct a series of space experiments to
see how they would affect the
development of Life what would a
creature living near an orange dwarf
look like could life still exist after a
supernova explosion and what the hell is
this join us in 1224 and find out and of
course you can also use it to plan and
Humanity's next steps towards greatness
to celebrate what may be our most
glorious calendar yet we've prepared a
few spectacular limited deals for you
thank you so much for being a part of
our story and for coming together every
year to make all of this possible see
you in
[Music]